uh she is the co-anchor of America
reports Sandra Smith is with us Sandra
what are we learning from the voters
tonight hey Sean a really interesting
stuff is coming in and especially when
it comes to that uh magga voter um it's
telling us a lot about how president
Trump is having a really good night
there in Iowa take a look this is some
of the key findings so far when it comes
to the Maga supporters in our Fox News
analysis uh more than six in 10 of them
of those caucus goers that identify as
Maga um the vast majority of them close
to eight in 10 it is revealed are
breaking for Donald Trump uh he still
appears to be king of the Maga World 77%
of them but looking at the moderate
voters this is a key group that we were
watching heading into Iowa this appears
to give some hope to Nikki Haley now
when it comes to those moderate voters
she doesn't beat Donald Trump there but
she's well ahead of Dan santis and Ramis
Swami among moderate voters this may
reflect something about her potential
strength in a general election so that
is a key takeaway now let's take a look
at another very key group there in Iowa
and that is the Evangelical Christian
voter this is a sizable group in Iowa we
all know that we've been watching that
heading into Iowa with this group Dan
santis courted them was even endorsed by
Bob Vander plat as we know but they love
Donald Trump DeSantis is 40 points
behind him and just Five Points ahead of
Haley all right so another key finding
with Trump is the fact that he is still
facing multiple in investigations and
indictments so we put the question to
voters this for the most part does not
appear to be a factor for Co caucus
goers look at this more than half think
the former president did nothing wrong
on January 6th half think the same about
interference in the 2020 election that
bumps down to 4 in 10 as you can see
when it comes to classified documents at
is Florida home overall though Iowa
Republicans think the investigation of
the former president are political not
legitimate so take a look at this
another key finding and a question that
we put to voters when it comes to those
Trump charges close to eight and 10 say
the charges against Trump are political
only two and say two and 10 say
legitimate and speaking of legitimate
more than six in 10 caucus goers say
President Biden was not legitimately
elected four years ago this is when we
put this question to voters those who
think Biden's election was on the up and
up clicking yes here they're backing
Nikki Haley those who don't break
strongly close to three quarters for
Donald Trump and finally one other hot
button issue among Iowa Republicans is
what is being taught in schools so we
asked about three issues and here is
what they said in some of the top finest
ings that we took away from the Fox News
voter analysis School teachings half say
K8 k through eight schools are teaching
too much Sean about racism but look
close to three qus of caucus attendees
think schools are focusing too much on
sexual orientation and gender identity
these are some really revealing
numbers something to dig into Sean and
brand new information just for you all
right Sandra great job fascinating the
way people think what goes into their
voting day of voting uh hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else